[Aplausos]
[Música]
antes a gente tratar do tema em si nós
vamos trabalhar com três histórias
histórias reais mas que para proteger a
identidade das vítimas
nós optamos por dar nomes fictícios e
escolhemos também histórias de contextos
socioeconômicos e culturais
diferenciados também para preservar a
identidade das vítimas
a primeira história aconteceu nos
estados unidos há muito tempo atrás 1947
foi quando uma jovem chamada quente ela
tinha 23 anos ela decidiu um belo dia de
sol
subi ao empire state para ver a cidade
como qualquer outra pessoa quando outras
pessoas turistas que vão à nova iorque
querem almirante para conhecer a cidade
de si só que keith diferente daqueles
outros turistas foi falar pro outro
motivo
cage foi para se matar
ela pulou de de 170 andares
isso representa basicamente o impacto
que como ela caiu em cima da limosine
curiosamente o seu corpo que era de uma
jovem bonita uma jovem que parecia
alegre
uma jovem que nenhuma pessoa poderia
imaginar que tivesse em mente
por fim a sua própria vida estava ali
naquele momento em cima de uma limousine
só que a limosine havia sido destruída
pelo impacto do corpo
isso tudo gerou muita polêmica como gera
nas nossas vidas porque será que uma
jovem de 23 anos bonita alegre e que
estava prestes a casar resolve se matar
foi aí que a investigação policial que
descobriram no bolso de seu casaco um
bilhete
o bilhete havia várias perguntas a si
mesmo mas eu escolhi uma pergunta
específica que na verdade não foi feita
por ela foi feita por familiares como o
próprio noivo que disse como ela pode
ter se matado se um dia anterior ao ato
ela estava comigo estando feliz falando
do seu casamento
mas de repente ele ver que aquela
aparente alegria havia sido transformado
em uma tragédia pois bem isso não foi só
com noivo de kate foi também com os seus
pais e amigos que entrar em desespero
como qualquer um de nós porque não
entende o que havia
mas o mistério foi revelado quando os
policiais leram por seus familiares
a fala de kate ele está melhor sem mim
eu nunca serei uma boa esposa para
ninguém
a pergunta continua no ar o suicídio é
complexo não só no entendimento do
porquê da morte mas do que há de mais
profundo no na subjetividade de cada um
uma frase como essa muitos de nós
ficaremos a ala foi traída a ela tem
baixa estima
cada um teria uma explicação mas nenhum
de nós seríamos capazes de decifrar
realmente qual foi a causa dessa morte
de terceiros
a segunda história não é muito diferente
ela vai mesmo sentir a história de um
jovem que aparentemente é um jovem
promissor também americano tinha 27 anos
tinha acabado de encarna doutorado para
a universidade presto quem não quer ir
pra universidade de protesto
quem não quer ser um programador de
tecnologia quem não quer ser um grande
inventor reconhecido
por toda a sociedade pois é bill era
diferente eu trazia dentro dele algo que
ninguém sabia o que era algo que todos
desconheciam porque só via o que
aparentemente a sociedade coloca como
importante o sucesso profissional de um
jovem bonito inteligente com sucesso
para um futuro promissor
o sucesso estava garantido mas havia uma
informação que ninguém sabia sabe com
essa informação o jovem bill de 23 anos
desde os 4 anos de idade sofria abuso
sexual de um pedófilo
ele não identificou também quando deixou
a macaca quem era o seu agressor no quem
era a pessoa que estava próxima dele que
havia feito aquilo
ele apenas fez questão de revelar o
mundo que ninguém conhecia o mundo de
alguém que sofria muito que se sentia
sozinho e que não podia contar com
ninguém e principalmente contar o seu
maior segredo que era o abuso sexual
foi aí que ele tomou coragem
essa história é bem recente foi em
janeiro de 2012
ele resolve se enforcar o seu próprio
quarto
mas ele também deixou uma carta só que
ele deixou uma carta no facebook e
mandou também para os seus pais e amigos
mais próximos
um e meio contando o quanto ele sofria
um dos sofrimentos mais dolorosos que
ele conta foi o quanto aquela burla
aquele abuso sexual havia afetado a vida
dele de relacionamento durante toda a
sua vida nem mesmo amar alguém e ele
conseguia mais
ele não conseguia entender sua utilidade
ele não conseguia sp entender como
sujeito
ele simplesmente só spin só responde às
demandas da sociedade
ele precisava ser um jovem de sucesso
halo de presto pesquisador de de alta
porta mas ele não queria viver daquela
forma porque ele vive uma mentira
em casa ele também não tinha
conhecimento
sabe por quê porque os pais não
enxergavam os meus pais só queriam que
ele estudasse e fosse um filho que fosse
hoje a sua
se tivesse a mesma preferência religiosa
de seus pais
foi então quando se o seu pai não
entendendo o porquê que ele não queria
ser um religioso que decide expulsá lo
de casa
aquela situação só piorou e aí ele deixa
o seu relato o quanto a ausência daquele
acolhimento quando ele se sentia sozinho
no mundo gelado
foi por isso que escolhi trazer mais um
relato quando ele diz que aquele momento
só ele podia entender o desejo de
declarar minha sanidade mental
justificar as minhas ações
elas não são capazes de fazer cada um de
vocês
reconheço a decisão dele como legítima
só ele sabia por que só ele entende o
sofrimento dele
por isso ele se vê no mundo de escuridão
que o seguiu durante toda sua vida e
naquele momento ele estava terminando
aquele gelo que o acompanhou o tempo
todo
essa história de bío-bío é mais uma
vítima de abuso sexual que acontece
todos os dias e que nós não sabemos
seja por dificuldades táticas seja
também porque nós não enxergamos quem
está do nosso lado
por último a terceira história é a diana
agora não é mais uma de um jovem é de
uma adolescente
essa adolescente tinha 15 anos
só que ela teve uma idéia de passar o
tempo na internet atender um pedido de
um estranho
já o estranho pediu para ela fazer strip
tease na frente do computador
só que eu não imaginava que aquela
imagem ia vir alisar o homem
desconhecido que pediu para fazer um
strip tease
ele também divulgou aquelas fotos a vida
de ana passou a ser infernal
ela não tinha mais pais na escola ela
passou a ser perseguida pelo próprio
desconhecido
e mais ela passo passou a sofrer até
mesmo o espancamento e ironias de amigos
que não entende por que que ela havia
exposto o corpo dela era uma jovem de 12
anos ela viveu entre os 12 e os 15 anos
tentando buscar uma saída
só que ela também não encontrou uma
saída ela se sentia só e deixou como
outros dois casos duas histórias um
bilhete
nesse bilhete ela dizia todo dia pelos
porque ainda estou aqui não tem ninguém
preciso de alguém como ela encontrou ela
desistiu da vida
eu não quero analisar essas histórias se
tornará generalizada las porque esse não
é o meu objetivo aqui eu comecei a minha
fala trazendo essas histórias apenas
para impactar a vocês que estão aqui
para entender que o suicídio é algo que
pode estar presente com que a história
de vida que até mesmo do seu lado mas
para isso a gente precisa ver essas
histórias nos permite fazer uma análise
de um quebra cabeça
o que elas têm em comum essas histórias
precisavam ser contadas para que todos
vocês entendesse que todas as vítimas
deram sinais mas ninguém conseguiu ver
esses sinais
e aí a gente precisa entender o suicídio
porque mais do que os dados
a gente precisa entender os porquês e
acima de deus porque a gente precisa
entender o que fazer
esse é o meu objetivo aqui hoje traseira
sistema que aparenta
mente é difícil é chato é complicado
ouvir incomoda mas a gente precisa
encarar
se queremos um futuro seguro com
qualidade com tecnologia e com o
progresso de uma coletividade saudável
bem o suicídio como disse nos estados
unidos e no canadá
são tendências que são de países que
sempre tiveram altas taxas de suicídio
o brasil ao contrário não tem esse
padrão de taxa como por exemplo do leste
europeu ou até mesmo no canadá o brasil
se vocês olharem a taxa em 2000 era 4
por 100 mil a ser muito pouco realmente
mas se a gente fizer uma análise dos
últimos 20 anos
a gente vai ver que o suicídio cresceu
56% da taxa
isso não é e quando a gente vê o que o
problema da taxa de suicídio ele ainda
maior de determinados grupos grupos de
risco que tipo de grupo
por exemplo quando olhamos para o grupo
de sexo e idade sexo e idade diferencia
a grupos de pessoas que têm maior risco
quando a gente olha por exemplo em país
não podemos olhar para a taxa a gente
tem que perguntar que país nós estamos
olhando por exemplo no brasil como
outros países que têm taxas maiores com
exceção da índia e da china a taxa de
suicídio é maior entre os homens é maior
entre os homens
mas ele é menor entre as mulheres as
mulheres tentam mais suicídio
muitas pessoas vão dizer porque tudo
também depende não só do contexto
cultural mas depende também do meio em
que essas pessoas utilizam quando a
gente olha ainda pela idade fica ainda
mais complexo porque a gente vai ver a
grande novidade que é o suicídio de
jovens grupos etários a gente viu que o
mapa
violência público há pouco tempo que nos
últimos 20 10 anos a taxa visto que de
suicídio de jovens de 15 a 29 anos havia
crescido em 10%
só que quando a gente olha que no grupo
de adolescentes de 10 a 14 anos
desculpa a gente vê que essa taxa ela
dobra e assim vai
ainda mais quando a gente considera não
só a idade mas também o grupo de homens
e mulheres
a gente vai ver que essa taxa também ela
aumenta para os adolescente e continua
crescente entre os homens jovens de 15 a
29 anos nos últimos 20 anos
o que a gente tem certeza que o suicídio
de jovens se tornou um problema que não
é novo
a gente tem dito das taxas a gente tem
dito dos problemas de qualidade de
informação
mas o que a gente não sabe ainda são os
porquês porque jovens tentou suicídio
porque jovens morre por suicídio
a gente pode dizer que o fator
sócioeconômico é um problema importante
para entender o problema do suicídio
nesse grupo de jovens e principalmente o
problema da rede do rendimento escolar
outro fator são as famílias
disfuncionais como a gente viu no início
na história de bill foi muito impactante
saber que os pais tinham também um
problema de fazer parte da história do
abuso físico sexual no sentido de não
perceber essas histórias e o bullying
envolvendo a ana e por último a gente vê
que esses jovens como muitos outros
estudos clínicos feitos nos estados
unidos e até mesmo aqui no brasil em
campinas mostra que a taxa de suicídio
dos jovens de 15 a 29 anos e dia
adolescentes também de 10 a 14 anos
implica entender
a depressão a ansiedade o tempo de uso
de internet e redes sociais e
principalmente o uso de drogas como ana
também fez como recurso para poder
acabar com a sua própria vida na sua
inúmeras tentativas que ela também fez
bem a gente precisa entender que esse
problema ele não tem só o impacto social
individual ele também tem um pacto
social porque se a gente entender que
pessoas individualmente sofre a gente
também precisa entender que pessoas
sofrem sozinhas mas a sociedade paga
caro por isso
se a gente for analisar o número de
internações do sus em termos de tempo
médio de permanência o gasto e o custo
por dia a gente vai ver que as mortes
por causas externas entre elas estão o
suicídio os acidentes homicídios
o valor gasto em 2000 em que a taxa já é
alta e agora continua ainda mais crescer
você vê que era em torno de 100 reais
por dia enquanto mortes naturais 68
reais por dia
eu não quero falar só de coisas ruins eu
quero falar também que há jeito eo jeito
pra isso que nós encontramos
enquanto pesquisadores que tentamos
entender esses fenômenos que afetam
individualmente mas afeta essencialmente
à sociedade como um todo
nós criamos os gp's pi grupo de estudo e
pesquisa suicídio e prevenção esse grupo
visa trabalhar não só produzindo
conhecimento mas acima de tudo
produzindo estratégias propostas para
que a sociedade possa enfrentar esse
problema através de diagnósticos
o primeiro diagnóstico nós produzimos
foi o suicídio entre policiais militares
mas por que estudar policiais militares
porque quando policiais imitar esse mato
ele também diretamente estamos matando
porque ele é o responsável pela provisão
de um bem público que se chama segurança
pública que é por acaso muito escassa em
nosso estado
a gente precisa conhecer um pouco do
sofrimento dos policiais pra isso nós
publicamos este livro é o resultado
dessa pesquisa
depois disso
criamos palestras institucionais
trabalhando com gestores policiais e
profissionais de saúde
fizemos também palestras nos batalhões
fizemos o workshop se formando pessoas
da área de saúde para poder atuar nas
suas instituições
criamos um curso de formação de
multiplicadores para que o policial
pudesse aprender a identificar os sinais
como eu falei no início a nossa conversa
criamos os karts que são carlos são
informações do que é o suicídio como
fazer pra poder lidar com o suicídio e
principalmente para onde encaminhar por
último
pensando no aumento do suicídio entre
jovens nós passamos a atuar agora nas
escolas porque fazer esse trabalho
implica como a gente viu custa caro para
o estado mas também custa caro para a
sociedade por isso a gente precisa
trabalhar nas escolas
quando a gente vai para a escola fazer
esse trabalho a gente vê que o suicídio
pode ser prevenido a morte custa caro
mas salvar vidas é barato porque nós
fazemos ações pequenas como por exemplo
palestras de sensibilização fazemos
cuida oferecemos cursos para os jovens
de escolas de ensino médio como foi o
caso do que eu contei da menina de 15
anos lá no canadá
fazemos também cursos para professores e
por último essa iniciativa nós não
começamos mas já estamos a fazer que é
desenvolver treinamentos para gerar
gentilezas compaixão e generosidade
entre jovens porque só assim poderemos
prevenir o sofrimento emocional porque
aprender com essa psicóloga karina de
são paulo de que a sociedade se a
sociedade não aprender a acolher o
sofrimento humano
nós vamos continuar tendo o suicídio nós
vamos continuar tendo taxas tão altas e
um grande desafio para a sociedade como
um todo que não é nem só pra mim mas
também nem só do grupo de pepe
o trabalho de todos nós enquanto
sociedade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]